please and um without further ado
let's let's start and i look forward to
the talk thank you elizabeth
thanks um okay let's have an attempt to
at this
uh yeah so i'm gonna talk about
counter-example guided inductive
synthesis
modulo theories and the idea behind this
algorithm
is that it uses a theory solver to
verify
generalized candidate solutions and to
return more general counter examples and
by doing this
it's able to synthesize programs
containing arbitrary constants that
elude other solvers
so this is the outline of what i plan to
talk about
so i'm going to give a bit of a sort of
motivation
not too much of an overview of sigis
because we've probably had most of that
by this point
then i'll dive into the algorithm in
detail and the evaluation
i'll talk about so as andy mentioned
there's an implementation of this
in cbc4 so i'll talk briefly about that
and then i want to quickly cover some
ongoing work where we go beyond these
arbitrary constants
so if you recall sieges is solving
this problem of does there exist a
program p
for all inputs x such that this
specification is satisfied and the spec
here i've used sigma to denote this but
this
pattern of alternating between a learner
and a verifier is
very common in automated reasoning and
if we quickly step through how siegis
does this alternation
in a standard sieges loop your
synthesizer
will be looking for a program that
works that satisfies the spec for all
x i where x i is a subset of the
possible inputs and that subset is the
counter examples
it's obtained so far
if it can't find one then it'll it'll
say there's no program in your grammar
not very many synthesizers will actually
do that
if it can find a candidate it'll then
pass that candidate to the verifier
and the verifier then set then looks for
a counter example
is there an is there an x such that
sigma isn't
isn't satisfied and if no counter
example exists then we have a solution
if one does exist then we pass back this
single this single value for x
the counter example to the synthesis
phase and then the loop repeats
this counter example is appended to the
x eyes
now i'm going to use an analogy to
highlight
one of the limitations of this of this
counter example guided alternating loop
so there's a guessing game that you
might have played as a child
and the idea is it's a two player game
player one thinks of an object i like to
name my stick figures alessandra and
daniel after my co-authors
so alessandro thinks of an object and
daniel tries to find out what that
object is by asking questions
that alessandro can answer with a yes or
a no
and this is a little bit like segas
so you can think of daniel as being a
bit like the synthesizer in sieges
he's searching for a solution and
alessandro is a bit like the verifier
he's he's checking daniel's solution and
he's giving
he's giving yet or no answers whether
it's right or wrong
and it's not it's not quite like segas
because
alessandro is only giving single bit
answers he's only giving yes or no he's
not giving
whereas in sieges you get you get a
number you get a literal
counter example rather than just a yes
no but let's ignore that for now
um i want to focus on the main reason
this is different to sigis
which is that daniel is asking questions
about the solution
whereas in sieges the synthesizer
doesn't ask questions about the
candidate
it gets us complete candidates and it
just says is this one right
is this one right is this one right and
that would be a bit like playing the
game like this
and clearly this is this is quite silly
um it's gonna take daniel a long time to
get the right solution
in the worst case scenario he has to
enumerate through all of the possible
objects in the universe
um but sega sigis doesn't do that right
does it um does it well
actually i'm going to tell you that
sometimes it does
and so i'm gonna i'm gonna give you an
example
this example is an invariant so if we
recall the invariance we had in the
first talk
this is this is a safety invariant for a
loop
in some code and we want to find an
invariant
so that such that it holds in the
initial state
and it holds after every iteration of
the loop
and then sorry to interrupt we're still
on slide 16 i thought you might want to
know
i don't have a solution for this uh i'm
on slide 25.
um all right uh i'll i'll
i can share let's see
uh you'll need me to you'll need me to
stop sharing first
yes just a second
um
and
you've missed a whole series of very
excellent drawings
so let's go from 16 to 25.
okay so here's the enumeration
yeah okay so we have
uh we're trying to find we're trying to
find a safety invariant
um such that these properties hold so
it holds before the loop it holds every
iteration of the loop
and it if it holds after the loop then
the assertion
is the assertion is true um and if we
skip to the next slide it will give you
an example solution just to save you
having to work it out in your head
and there are there are multiple
different answers to this
but if we have a look at how seagus
might
tackle this um so
if we jump on to the next slide we can
look at away see so
this would have been animated and we can
look at how sega's
might might have tackled this we jump
into the middle of it solving it
it was looking for it's
it's looking for this possible solution
that bounds x
with an upper and a lower bound but
suppose that it's found this the
candidate solution
x less than 95 and
it passes that to the verifier and the
verifier looks at that and it says no
this doesn't work when x is equal to 95
and gives that count for example the
synthesizer and the next solution we get
may be x less than 96 um
and then the verifier will then say well
that doesn't work for x equal to 96
and pass that back to the synthesizer
and so on
and you can see how this loop repeats
and we end up
enumerating through x less than
this constant literal through all of the
constant literals until we get to a
thousand and three before we discover
that we actually need a lower bound as
well
and so if daniel reaches a solution
quicker
by asking more general questions
can we do that in sieges the question is
can we go
from the first illustration we had um
to can we next slide um can we go from
the first illustration we had
where we're enumerating through objects
to asking more general questions
in sieges and the answer is yes
otherwise i wouldn't be giving this talk
but
let's first consider another difference
between the game and sieges
so in sieges the synthesizer and the
verifier are working together
so if daniel can ask better questions
perhaps
alessandro could give more informative
general answers
and perhaps the game could go something
like this
um you're going to have to flip through
a lot of slides now
so as as daniel names objects
alessandro can provide more informative
reasons why the objects are incorrect
and this is this is the key this is this
is another key point of cst
what we want to know is we want to know
if if alessandra can be more helpful
then perhaps the sieges verifier can be
more helpful
too and if we skip forward a couple of
slides
um this is what sega's t is sigis t
is asking more general questions
and giving more general answers
in essence it's broadening the
communication between the synthesizer
and the verifier
um so if we if we jump into some of the
detail now
um sega's t is inspired
by dplt um
so if we look at the next slide dpllt
combines a theory solver with a
propositional sat solver
and what it does is it constructs this
boolean formula
that's effectively a generalization of
the
original formula and it finds an
assignment to that boolean formula
and then it passes that boolean formula
to a theory solver
and that tries to work out whether the
assignment is possible
on the original formula and if it's not
it passes back a clause that blocks that
assignment
and the more general the clause the
faster the solver
and sigiste on the next slide
takes standard sieges and it appends a
theory solver to it
so it attaches a first order theory
solver to it on the next slide
and so what happens is
when the verifier block finds a
candidate program that doesn't work
it will generalize it and pass that to a
theory solver
and then the theory solver will work out
if the general program
is a solution and if not it will produce
a clause that blocks that general
program
so we can see that when we get to the
verifier there are
in the original sieges loop we send a
counter example immediately back to the
synthesizer
if we go on to the next slide what
happens in sigis t
is we take this candidate program p star
and we generalize this program in a in a
generalization
phase and i'm going to talk about one
specific
instance of generalization which is
based around
constant literals so what we do
is we replace all of the constant
literals
in this candidate program by a vector of
symbolic values
which gives us p star v and other
methods of generalization
might be possible but i'm going to focus
on this on this specific
instance and then on the next slide we
can see that
p star v is then passed to the deduction
step
and the deduction steps job is to figure
out if the generalized program
could be a solution and if not to block
the generalized program
so effectively what it's doing
is it's asking does there exist a
valuation for v
that makes x less than v of valid
invariants
and if there is so it wants to say can i
find a v such that p
star v is a solution and if there is it
can then
return that that concrete solution and
if there isn't
it wants to block p star v with a clause
um a key thing to notice here is that
this is a first order formula because
the quantifiers are over the variables
um so yeah okay so that's c is t but the
question is what kind of theory solver
do we need for this
and in the paper at cav we looked at two
theory solvers
we looked at a standalone implementation
of fourier moscon
and we looked at an smt solver so we
used z3
but essentially the requirements are it
must be able to solve
first order formula with arbitrary
propositional structure
and with a single quantifier alternation
um so if we skip to the next slide we
can look at
how we do this in the implementation we
have
um so this formula potentially could
take a while to solve
especially if it's sat so what we do is
we'll split it into multiple parallel
formula
um and this could be done by a first
order solver
and we we simply did it because the
solvers we had were overwhelmed with the
formula we were giving them
and so what we've done is we've split it
by adding constraints
on the symbolic variables that we
introduced um so
bounding them with some constant c
and we've pulled this constant c out of
the candidate program but this is just a
heuristic
you could bound it anywhere you like you
could
bound it like you could pick this
constant however you like we've got a
heuristic that happens to work
um so we can see on the example
invariant we had
we had a candidate that was x less than
95
and we've generalized that to get x less
than v
and then we want to swap these we want
to bound these v
variables with some constant and we can
see
on the next slide that that constant is
that we use is 95.
so this is still so we solve these
formula in parallel
these are still fairly hard formula so
there are three different outcomes for
these
subproblems they can either be sat
unsat or they can time out
and what we do depends on the results so
over the so on the next slide we can see
that if both are
unset then we block the whole of p star
if one of them is unset and the other
one doesn't finish
then we re return a constraint on v so
that constraint will say
if your candidate program is the same
general structure as p
star then make sure that constants are
within these bounds
and then we can and then obviously if
one of the formula is sat
then we can return then we've got a
solution and we can return a solution
and the final outcome is that neither
finish within the timeout
and if they both time out then we
default to normal sieges
so let's look at some results
we implemented our prototype over bit
vector benchmarks
without a syntactic template um
and we compared to cbc4 because
everybody compares to cbc4
um so if we have a look at the
graph a couple of slides ahead um
in the original set of experimental
results we
managed to solve more benchmarks on cpc4
although we were in general slower
um it sort of keeps plodding on and
eventually manages to solve them
and this is against cbc4 1.5
so uh on the next slide i want to give
cbc4 the credit is due
we then compared to 1.7 and our
comparison didn't go
quite so well um
but if we skip forward a bit i can
now talk about there is now actually a
sigis t implementation
in cbc four um
so the implementation is in cvc4 1.7 and
onwards
and it uses itself as its own first
order solver
and it supports sigis t with syntactic
templates which is nice
um there are a couple of key differences
so instead of so when we implemented
sega's t
we search through concrete solutions
and cvc4 searches through templates in
the synthesis phase
and then it passes those to the verifier
um
yeah that's that's really the key
difference so it's searching through
templates rather than needing to do the
generalization
phase and on this set of results
um so i've given you the results for one
specific use case
where cst has turned out to be quite
beneficial inside cbc4
and this is so i think andy briefly
mentioned this
these are the invertibility conditions
which are used for
so i think they were used for floating
point formula and i think there was a
cav paper in 2019 on this
um yeah and we found
that sigis t on these benchmarks it
solves
so we compared it against both the naive
sigis implementation
inside cbc4 and um there's an option in
cvc4 where you simply add every constant
that is in the specification
onto the um on onto the
onto the grammar we can stay on the
results slide we're wrong by the way
um yeah so you can see we can see that
we've managed to solve more benchmarks
and
it's on average 20 seconds faster on the
mutually sold benchmarks so if you
build this into a virtual best solver
you gain about 50
you gain about 50 seconds
um yeah so
um so uh to conclude the sega's t
section um we've solved
program synthesis by uh can we skip to
the next slide
yeah so we've solved program synthesis
via first order solvers that support
quantifiers
and to do this we've done this by
verifying generalized candidate
solutions
and returning more general counter
examples
and the key thing to note is that this
is broadening the communication channel
between the synthesizer and the verifier
so if we flip forward a couple of slides
i want to talk about how so what i want
to talk about
briefly is how we can go beyond
constants for this
um so
can we flip forwards yeah thank you
yeah so i talked about one specific type
of generalization
um which only works for constants um
but one of the things that we're working
on now
is a framework that will allow us to to
go
from to expand this communication
channel using oracle guided synthesis
so the theoretical framework has been
set out in the
paper a theory of formal synthesis fire
inductive learning by sushmit jar and
sanjit seisha
and the basic idea is that
you have a synthesis phase or a learner
and an oracle
and the communication between them
is through a pattern of queries and
responses and so the queries are defined
to be in some set of queries
and the responses are defined to be in
some set of responses
so if we look at the illustration on the
next slide
in the case of sega's t the query is
is my program correct and the response
there's a number of responses um so if
we look at the next slide
the response can be either yes your
program is correct
or it can be no and all of the programs
of
this sort of structure are wrong or no
but if i replace the constants in your
program then it is correct
or no and if you're going to use a
program that
looks like this that has this program
structure make sure the constants are in
these ranges
and so what we want to do is we want to
allow
so a future direction for saigas is that
we want to
um can we go to the next slide is that
we want to allow
more like the user to specify the
queries and the responses between the
synthesizer and the oracle
and so we've introduced a syntactic
extension into sagas if for this
and this would allow the user to specify
how broad this query
the query and response paths could be
and the question of what type of queries
and responses could you have well you
could have any provided that it can
return
some kind of logical constraint provided
the response can be some kind of
logical constraint
um so to conclude
um yeah so to conclude i've talked about
cst
the main point of sega's t is that
broader communication between the
verifier and the and the synthesizer
is good broadening this communication
allows you to reduce the search space
faster
um and i would argue that the main
insight here is that the oracle should
provide
all of the information it has available
if it would be useful to the synthesizer
but this can we have the next slide
this does make the game quite short if
you provide all the information you have
um are there any questions and thank you
for the fantastic slide changing
questions other questions from people we
do have two minutes uh
to the official end
okay i'll i'll start with the question
so uh
is it correct to say that the current
work not the proposed future work is
related to inequalities where values
uh come from numeric intervals or is it
currently more general than that already
um do you mean this best if
uh so it will so the current work
basically will look for
um constant literals in your solution so
it will it will only work for problems
where you need
constant literals in the solution um
there's no specific constraint
over the over the specif the type of
specification you can have though
but i assume that the benefits usually
occur when you have inequalities right
in the example the counter example is
not specific enough
because it is a loose bound on those
intervals or other other cases where
uh so it is true that's a case where
where you do benefit from it um
i think
that's not necessarily the cases where
you find so the cases where you benefit
are typically the cases where you'll
find that people when they've written
syntactic templates
have had to provide a constant literal
in the syntactic template or very
specific constant literals
um so examples of that might be so
things that involve
bit vector manipulation if you need to
shift
by some very specific number
like anything where your solution
involves some kind of specific value
that
you might not have in the spec
so i understand that but i was curious
whether in those cases where there are
no
inequalities there are actually benefits
from having the more general counter
examples
i guess the question becomes would the
more general counter example block
more solutions than a concrete one
right um i think the real
payoff comes so the real payoff from
cgst
is that you m is that you managed to
search for these to to search for the
solution the concrete solution within
the general template like that's where
you get the biggest gains
rather than returning the counter
example um
so and actually so cvc4 only cvc4
doesn't return the generalized counter
examples it's only our prototype that
returns the generalized
counter examples so the payoff in the
cbc4
implementation is that you're passing
temp general solutions to the verifier
and then the verifier is trying to
complete them
thank you
do we have any additional questions
uh in that case i want to thank
elizabeth and all the
uh speakers here for fantastic
presentations
i assume we would love to collect the
slides and post those in addition to the
recorded talks
right in that case we need to contact
ashley so i will just ask all the
speakers and i will put
i will ask ashley if she could actually
if you're there could we put slides
online
ashley's not there yet anyway speakers
for now
yes just send a name just send your
slides please to ashley
and we will ask her if she could put
them online uh
because she's in the charge of uh
maintaining the website
and also she was the one who contacted
you for uh titles and abstracts and
everything she put everything online so
just for now send slides to ashley and
we will ask her if she could put them
slides
only thank you
thank you and see you all next week bye